well another week another major news
story related to ufos the new york times
is reporting
about the contents of a soon to be
released pentagon investigation
into the ufo mystery yeah the times says
the report to congress will leave
open the question of whether some ufos
are indeed alien
spacecraft george knapp has our story
[Music]
the initial new york times headline
declared government finds no evidence
ufos are alien spacecraft then clarified
things in a later
headline that added the government can't
rule out alien tech
either a more accurate headline could
have been pentagon says we don't know
what ufos are
or the real news in the story pentagon
says ufos are not secret american
technology
unnamed officials who've seen a
classified report not yet provided to
congress
told the times the report analyzes 120
ufo incidents
from over the past 13 years much of the
evidence was previously compiled into a
briefing document
produced by the uap task force a report
that includes
startling images of craft considered to
be true
unknowns a few images and videos from
that report have already been made
public by mystery wire
and filmmaker jeremy corbell photos
taken by navy pilots off the east coast
and videos recorded by the navy off the
west coast
unknown objects that surrounded nine
warships in july 2019
two other incidents evaluated by the uap
task force
the so-called gimbal ufo event off
florida in 2015
and the tic tac incident off southern
california in 2004
the time says the unreleased report
leaves open the question of whether the
amazing technology
might belong to a foreign adversary
david fravor the pilot who chased the
tic tac
shared his opinions with us in 2019
if you'd asked me in 2004 i didn't know
my thing is it's now almost 15 years
later and that technology is still there
no one has figured it out or no one has
seen it
you can hide stuff you can hide stuff
for a long time but hiding stuff for 15
years
is i think it gets harder and harder if
the time story is accurate then the
upcoming ufo report will be amazingly
similar to this
assessment written by an american
general back in 1947
which basically said these things are
real but we don't know whose they
are the biggest news in the time story
is that the report essentially will rule
out the possibility
that secret american military tech is
responsible for the most notable ufo
incidents
former nevada senator harry reid who
co-sponsored the predecessor program to
the uap
task force has said all along that the
russians and chinese
are also studying the ufo mystery for
the same reason we are
meaning they're not ours lou elizondo
who spent 10 years as head of the atip
ufo investigation says the technology
seen by u.s
pilots is beyond anything known on earth
he told mystery wire the u.s
russia and china are all in the same
boat
we may be dealing with something here
that we we really don't understand
because if we're having the same problem
that russia is in other countries
then then chances are this is a a a
this is a topic that is a mutual concern
and interest for
for for more than just the united states
in fact it would paint the picture that
this is not a u.s phenomenon at all but
this is rather a global phenomenon
the uap report is due in congress by
june 25th
what we don't know yet is what access
the task force
had to classified files and materials
stashed in dark corners of the pentagon
or cia
after 70 years of secrecy did the task
force crack that veil
in a mere six months retired
intelligence officer colonel john
alexander
doubts it well i think there's two
issues the most serious pushback you're
not going to see
that's going to happen behind the
curtain if you will
so it's where they say hell no we won't
go you know i'm not going to provide the
data
george knapp 8 news now well george adds
that the biggest difference between the
upcoming ufo report and previous
statements provided by the pentagon
is that the military is no longer being
dismissive of ufos
or trying to brush them off as swamp gas
or weather balloons